ja sehr herzlichen dank sind ja sonst
immer aufregerthemen die mitgebrachten
ich habe eine schöne entscheidung eines
oberlandesgerichtes mitgebracht was die
wirklich rechtsgeschichte schreiben
wirklich gerne vorstellen möchte er
möchte eine kleine geschichte zu
erzählen im jahr 1981 das ein ganz
interessanter kriminalfall der auf ihren
bekanntesten 1981 wurde die damals 17
jährige schülerin friederike von müller
man erst entführt dann wurde sie
vergewaltigt und schließlich ermordet
man hat dann einen mann als ihren
mutmaßlichen täter festgenommen martin
angeklagt er ist auch verurteilt worden
wegen vergewaltigung wegen mordes er hat
dann berufung gegen dieses urteil
eingelegt das ist dann bis zum
bundesgerichtshof hochgegangen der
bundesgerichtshof hatte das urteil
aufgehoben und am ende hat dieser mann
den gerichtssaal als freier mann
verlassen weil er aus mangel an beweisen
freigesprochen worden das war im jahre
1983 fast 30 jahre später gab es dann
aufgrund der fortentwicklung der
kriminaltechnik eine dna-analyse die mit
einer sehr hohen wahrscheinlichkeit
festgestellt hat dass dieser mann der
täter war weil man samen spuren bei der
vergewaltigung ihm zuweisen konnte und
jetzt würde man ja normalerweise denken
der muss doch jetzt wieder angeklagt
werden wir mussten ihm muss der prozess
gemacht werden er muss hinter schloss
und riegel das lässt aber unsere
strafprozessordnung nicht zu und das ist
etwas was ich als unerträglichen zustand
empfunden habe was glaube ich auch dem
rechtsempfinden der allermeisten
menschen in unserem land widerspricht
und deswegen haben wir als cdu csu
fraktion in der letzten wahlperiode ein
gesetz durchgesetzt auf den weg gebracht
was genau diesen missstand ab stehen
sollte was möglichkeiten schaffen sollte
diese verfahren wieder neu aufzurollen
gegen erhebliche widerstände die spd
justizministerin christine lambrecht das
aufs schärfste bekämpft auch die fdp im
bundestag und die grünen haben dagegen
gestimmt die wollten dass alle nicht
weil sie gesagt haben das ist alles
verfassungswidrig in unserer grundgesetz
ist es verboten jemanden zweimal zu
bestrafen was auch stimmt aber wie
gesagt natürlich muss es möglich sein in
diesen
fällen wo es um exzeptionelle unrecht
gibt so etwas zu machen und das haben
wir am ende durchsetzen können und jetzt
hat das oberlandesgericht celle weil
dieser mann aufgrund dieses neuen
gesetzes was erst wenige wochen in kraft
ist erneut festgenommen worden ist in
untersuchungshaft gesteckt worden ist
das hat das oberlandesgericht celle
gestern bestätigt hat gesagt ja die
untersuchungshaft ist rechtmäßig das
ganze gesetz ist auch verfassungsgemäß
also eine wirklich gute entscheidung so
und jetzt kommt aber dann doch der
aufreger die ampel der ist der
justizminister von der fdp und auch die
grünen die wollen jetzt möglicherweise
dieses gesetz wieder abschaffen die wahl
sagen nämlich das war ja alles an einem
freispruch unter vorbehalt das können
wir so nicht hinnehmen und ich glaube
das wäre wirklich ein affront wenn man
so etwas machen würde einer frau
gegenüber den parlamentarischen
gesetzgeber der letzten wahlperiode aber
vor allen dingen ein affront gegenüber
den angehörigen von mordopfern
die ampel hat sich selber in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag als ein bündnis für
gerechtigkeit bezeichnet und ich finde
wenn man gerechtigkeit ob wolken lassen
kann dann muss dieses gesetz bestehen
bleiben das sind wir den angehörigen
schuldig und das ist das was mich
persönlich gestern wahnsinnig bewegt hat
hallo die ampel hat das ja nicht ganz
ohne grund getan sondern es gibt einen
ganz ganz wichtigen grundsatz in unserem
rechtsstaat denn der rechtsstaat muss ja
nicht nur gewährleisten dass es
einzelfallgerechtigkeit gibt sondern er
muss eben auch dafür sorgen dass es
rechts frieden gibt und so tragisch dass
auch im einzelfall sein kann gibt es
eben einen ganz elementaren grundsatz in
unserem strafrecht und das ist der
grundsatz der die römer schon kennen aus
dem grundsatz des nebels in den sie auch
angesprochen hatten man solle nicht
zweimal in derselben sache nicht nur
verurteilt werden sondern es soll auch
in zwei mal kein prozess gegen
eingeführt werden wenn ein rechtsstaat
einmal ein verfahren gegen einen bürger
geführt hat und es dem rechtsstaat nicht
gelungen ist den strafanspruch des
staates zu beweisen und der bürger ist
also frei gesprochen worden dann ist es
ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz dass
man dann sagt damit ist wenn auch hier
das ganze in der dritten instanz schon
bis zum bgh gegangen ist in die revision
dann muss auch irgendwann rechtsfrieden
herrscht man muss auch irgendwann
schluss sein und dann kann der
rechtsstaat nicht kommen und sagen dass
er dann nach einigen jahrzehnten sich
nochmal die sache anschaut dann nochmal
neue beweismittel mit einbringt das geht
nur in ganz engen grenzen und diese ganz
engen grenzen hat die union hier
verlassen in der letzten
legislaturperiode aus den gründen der
einzelfall sicherheit und das ist
einzelfallgerechtigkeit ist ein
interesse aber es ist nicht das
vordringliche interesse in einem
strafprozess der schon einmal
durchgeführt wurde und dass herr luca
ist ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz
unterricht der auffassung liegt die
union völlig falsch aus gründen der
einzelfallgerechtigkeit den rechtsstaat
zu schleifen und damit sollten wir nicht
anfangen ich möchte ganz vehement
widersprechen sie habe zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass wir rechtsfrieden
brauchen rechtsfrieden ist ein ausfluss
der rechtsstaatlichkeit und das ist ein
ganz hohes gut da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
allerdings frage ich was kann denn ein
falscher freispruch an rechtsfrieden
tatsächlich bringen wenn hinterher klar
ist das ist ein mörder wir können es mit
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit
nachweisen und das sind ja die
voraussetzung ist ja nicht so dass man
jedes verfahren wieder öffnen kann
sondern die hürden sind hoch es geht um
exzeptionelle es unrecht um mord und
völkermord also verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit alles das was in unserer
rechtsordnung als unverlierbare
straftaten gewertet werden also wo ist
das unrecht wirklich mit händen zu
greifen ist nur in diesen
konstellationen sohnes gelten und ich
finde auch die die materielle
gerechtigkeit das ist auch
kernbestandteil unserer
rechtsstaatlichkeit und ich glaube wir
weil sie gerade sagt wir dürfen den
rechtsstaat nicht schreiben ich glaube
wir schleifen den rechtsstaat im
gegenteil dann wenn wir es zulassen dass
es solche falschen freisprüche gibt wo
evident ist dass sie falsch sind das
mindert die akzeptanz in den rechtsstaat
und das ist am ende ein viel größerer
schaden als wenn man jetzt in einem in
einer besonderen situation in einem
einzelfall aber in einer besonderen
situation die klar geregelt ist mit
klaren und strikten würden hier eine
solche wiederaufnahme des verfahrens
zulässt nein da muss da muss die
staatsanwaltschaft wenn eben zweifel
bestehen ob man das ganze durchsetzen
kann auf der basis der rechtslage dann
auch genau abwägen ob man auf dieser
beweislage schon das verfahren führen
will und ob man das verfahren zu ende
führen will wenn die staatsanwaltschaft
sich entscheidet und wenn das gericht
das ganze zur verhandlung zulässt und
dann wird diese verhandlung durchgeführt
dann muss auch irgendwann wenn dann
dieses verfahren zugunsten der person
die betroffen ist ausgeht dann muss auch
irgendwann schluss sein und dann kann
man nicht kommen und dann noch mal sagen
okay jetzt nehme ich die noch mal ran da
muss der rechtsstaat auch irgendwann da
ist das strafverfahren durchlaufen dann
hat diese person ein jahrelanger prozess
durchlaufen und wenn das dann geschehen
ist muss auch irgendwann der
rechtsfrieden herrschen man kann ich
dann wieder anfangen alles wieder von
vorne auf eine hochinteressante rechts
philosophische frage ich könnte
stundenlang zuhören sind sie beides
anwälte oder warum also dann leben wir
uns doch zurück und machen sogar richter
hold für das interessante ist wenn jeder
irgendwie jeder von ihnen spricht bin
ich immer der meinung von dem der
spricht gerade weil sich beide so
plausibel argumentieren
so ist es also fynn holpert viertel nach
acht immer mehr zum tausch der
gebildeten stände das begrüße ich sehr
demenz gibt es dann vielleicht noch
höhere kätzchen darstellen
selbstverständlich muss das jetzt
auflösen
ich würde als jemand der nicht jura
studiert hat dennoch ein doktortitel
hatte er sich nicht erschlichen hat ich
sage das primäre empfinden dass ich habe
ist das teilen vielleicht doch mehr
leute als hier am tisch sitzen wenn
jemand einen mord begangen hat dann soll
er dafür zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
das würde ich erst mal sagen und wenn er
jetzt halt irgendwie glück hat sich da
irgendwie durchgemogelt zu haben oder
denn der zeuge in dem moment als er
aufgefunden werden sollte ich auch
gefunden werden sollte oder vielleicht
technische möglichkeiten es später
kommen sie haben das erwähnte
dna-analyse gab sehr wenig wissen wir
alle wie columbo angucken die feuerwehr
hat allen 18 minuten gelöst mit dna gab
es damals nicht mehr viel aufwendiger
also ich würde einfach sagen wenn ihr
mann ein mord begangen hat ich habe
jetzt auch noch den kopf mord verjährt
nicht dann soll er vom rechtsstaat zur
verantwortung für diese böse tat gezogen
werden und wenn das erst 30 jahre später
ist aber dennoch eine gerechte strafe
ist würde ich sagen diese 20 jahren frei
dazwischen hat er nicht verdient und ich
weiß nicht was tut ein doktor gemacht du
hast mich die situation
also das ist sozusagen die die
rechtsfrieden oder uns ist hergestellt
und also bist du jetzt doch wieder auch
er bei akt das wort ich glaube bei
unverjährbar straftaten muss muss muss
man da wahrscheinlich muss man da
wahrscheinlich
muss man wahrscheinlich den
rechtsfrieden
hinstellen würden sich wahrscheinlich in
momentan ich will dem dringend
entgegentreten denn was ist verjährung
verjährung bedeutet das wenn ein prozess
nicht rechtzeitig angestrengt wird das
dann irgendwann keine verfolgung mehr
stattfinden kann wir sprechen hier aber
über einen frei wo im laufe der
laufenden verjährung mord verjährt nie
aber es ist bereits ein prozess
innerhalb der verjährung begonnen worden
und es ist auch dieser staatliche
strafanspruch geprüft worden und bis zu
ende geprüft worden das heißt es ist
keine verjährungsfrist das verfahren ist
durch und selbst wenn ich an die liegt
habe was nicht verkehrt wenn der staat
zum schluss kommt ich kann nicht
beweisen dass eine schuld vorlag und
deswegen gibt es einen freispruch dann
ist recht gesprochen dann ist dem
strafanspruch innerhalb der verjährung
genügt worden und die verjährung läuft
dann nicht weiter weil das verfahren
rechtskräftig abgeschlossen ist und
diese rechtskraft beseitigt ein
nochmaliger möglichkeit der staat nicht
nach einjähriger freispruch hat
natürlich ein geschmäckle also wenn er
bis zum falschparken oder ein
steuerdelikt geht will ich voll auf
ihrer seite aber wenn wir wissen das ist
ein mörder und sagen leider aus rechts
technischen gründen muss der frei
herumlaufen und muss ich sagen habe habe
ich auch ein problem und ich finde diese
differenzierung ist auch wichtig es geht
eben nicht um das knöllchen das geht
nicht um die einfache fahrlässige
körperverletzung oder es geht wirklich
um die konstellation wo unsere
rechtsordnung ganz elementar sagt das
wiegt so schwer dieses unrecht das ist
noch nicht einmal verliert das kann man
in 50 jahren immer noch anklagen wenn
man dann die entsprechenden beweise hat
und einer konstellation wo es auf der
hand liegt dass jemand der täter ist nur
um die konzentration geht es ja wo es
völlig klar ist aufgrund einer neuen
beweislage das ist der täter dann zu
sagen als rechtsordnung auch als
gesellschaft den lassen wir aber in
freiheit weiterlaufen das widerspricht
meinem rechtsempfinden zutiefst und ist
auch etwas was den rechtsfrieden eben
gerade nicht herstellt das ist am ende
eben auch die abwägung sie über zu
treffen haben rechtssicherheit auf der
einen seite da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
die es ist ein hohes gut aber die
materielle gerechtigkeit das ist doch
das streben eines strafprozesses
materielle gerechtigkeit herzustellen zu
sühnen und wenn das nicht
vollzogen werden kann weil es sozusagen
einen fall einen freispruch falsch ist
der aber hinterher als falsch erweist
dann muss man auch die möglichkeit haben
in der rechtsordnung das zu korrigieren
und das haben wir jetzt gemacht und
deswegen muss das auch bestehen bleiben
der freispruch ist nach der materiellen
rechtslage in dem zeitpunkt wo hergang
ist richtig gewesen da ist gar keine
frage da passt auch die maus keinen
faden ab das ist so und da muss man
einfach sagen prozessual und auch
materiell im zeitpunkt der
entscheidungsfindung dem staatlichen
anspruch ist genüge getan ich meine sie
reißen da eine ganz ganz gefährliche
linie 1 und wenn man damit anfängt dann
ist eben die frage wo hört man dann auf
sie sagen jetzt heute sollen die delikte
seien die nie verjähren okay vielleicht
ist es morgen ein anderes delikt
vielleicht ist es morgen auch der
steuersünder oder was eben gefallen ist
da muss man aufpassen das sind
grundsätze wenn wir sie einreichen wenn
wir damit anfangen eine mauer
einzureißen in dem moment kann es sein
dass sie für immer in sich